it's a unique and historic as Las Vegas
itself we're talking about burlesque
yeah downtowns in fact the burlesque
Hall of Fame it takes you through the
history of this glitzy American
tradition Candace Charles live in The
Newsroom with an inside look at this
week's Hidden Gem Candace good morning
to you good morning YouTube good morning
Fox burlesque is generally called The
Art of striptease but walking through
the last call of Fame in downtown Las
Vegas you can see it's so much more than
that a political message and art form
and certainly a piece of not only Nevada
history but American history
this is becoming burlesque they're
step-by-step instructions on how to do
classic burlesque moves a dance studio
in our exhibit an Avenue to burlesque
history the burlesque Hall of Fame is a
Hidden Gem with a multitude of treasures
we're telling them about a rich history
that is uniquely American Buttercup is
the programmed coordinator she takes
visitors through its history created by
renowned burlesque Entertainer Ginny Lee
and bought to Las Vegas by the late
Marilyn Monroe of burlesque Dixie Evans
the Hall of Fame has been offering a
tour since 2010. what we've come to
think of as a sort of traditional
topless show or Las Vegas showgirl show
has its roots directly in Burlesque
Dustin wax is the Hall of fame's
executive director he tells me much of
what you see in the museum was donated
from performers throughout the years and
earlier this month their annual
fundraiser the Weekender this is the
largest gathering of burlesque
performers from past to present with the
help of donations and the strong let's
Community Buttercup and wax are able to
keep the museum going inspiring the next
generation of stars through their school
of striptease we can do a tease make
sure you're looking at your audience and
reminding Hall of Fame visitors that
everyone has the capacity to express
themselves it's just a really important
part of our culture and we hope that it
has lessons for everyone that walks
through here
and they have guided tours four times a
week at an affordable price they have a
huge burlesque show coming up on July
15. we'll have those details on our
website 8newsnow.com for now live
Newsroom I'm Candace Charles 8 news now
really fun to get the back story Candace
thank you so much